cnn destroying what little credibility
the liberal network has left a new
report says top brass there suggested
primetime host chris cuomo take a
temporary leave of absence to help
advise his creepy governor brother
that's after we learned this week that
chris helped craft a statement against
one of andrew cuomo's accusers
i don't get the whole conflict of
interest there's conflicts throughout
the media everyone's
worked for the clinton administration
covers democrats or is married to
someone that is in the administration i
mean no one would be able to cover
anything if you actually had to abide by
conflict of interest rules there's
actually it's actually pretty
interesting how many people were married
amongst each other amongst the media or
the clinton administration and then the
obama administration yeah there's not so
much of that during the push not just so
much as i recall i've never been happier
that my sister works from home for a
great company and rescues three cats i
mean that's like really good because you
don't
on my show tonight that you're on we're
doing a whole segment on rescue cats
you're gonna have to stay out of this
okay well i guess i'll just step aside
that's what i would have done i think in
this case you have to make a choice
right you have to choose
it's not an easy choice necessarily but
you aren't you cannot write your
brother's statement
and also be an anchor could you cover
your brother honestly
i think that i you know i think there is
there is something to be said about you
know family it's like a man my goodness
you can't but but but the problem is i
watched cnn for the first time in months
years last night because i wanted to see
how compromised he looks and if there's
a problem here it has to do with the
nursing home stuff the q-tip it's not
just him and his his brother it's the
it's the i hate to use the word idiocy
again but it was the mockery of the
whole event with his brother the q-tip
the dating so i was watching him talk
about kobet and he's very very
passionate about it he's telling people
what to do he's commentating he's not
news reading he's commentating but every
advice he gave you in your head you're
going but wait you didn't do that but
wait you faked it when you were
quarantining but wait you were playing
with the q-tip but wait so it's very
hard to actually listen to him
now and it's kind of like he has that
stench when you're on poop island that
you can't get off
how much damage do you think his brand
has sustained on cnn after everything
that's happened deagon who chris cuomo
he has a brand well someone said highest
rated show on cnn that's like being the
tallest dwarf
and i know
congratulations thank you
seven years running he's like he's like
jeff zucker's rinfield
um
so i i just wanted to point out
something this is jeff zucker's network
right it's not there are no standards
there's no accountability the standard
is whatever makes jeffy happy we do it i
just want to note that today three
employees were
fired by cnn
for coming to the office unvaccinated
when they knew that they were ordered to
be vaccinated i just no i just want to
say and jeff zucker said we have a zero
tolerance policy on this so he has zero
tolerance for this but maximum tolerance
for big swinging
dirt bags oh speaking i'm not going to
go there
you're not big
all right
i know he's your friend or some would
say protege
chris cuomo try to be fair without a
conflict of interest and cover this
story
can i just talk about that q-tip
incident remember
the q-tip incident happened at a time
when it seemed as if new york state had
really done a great job and that uh
andrew cuomo was visionary in his uh in
his uh
countermeasures the first wave it was
after and it was it was perfect time
that's a great joke and they're brothers
and they love each other and i'm telling
you great joke it was it was a great
joke i mean
we talked about our big notes that's
hyperbole we talked about our big noses
all the time
it was wait i'm gonna stop you right
there look at the date on that video may
mid may of last year you know what we
knew back then that elderly people
coveted positive patients were sent back
into those nursing homes by his brain
you showed me in may of 2020 what you
said and i i challenged that not that
you know i had told you in the highest
regard
all right i just think that they they
talk
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else